CONFIDENT THIS BILL IS GOING TO
BOOST HIS PARTY COME NOVEMBER.
PAM.
>> ALL RIGHT.
MELANIE, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>>> LAST HOUR, I SPOKE WITH GINA
McCARTHY, THE WHITE HOUSE
NATIONAL CLIMATE ADVISER.
HERE'S PART OF THAT
CONVERSATION.
>> THIS IS GOING TO BE THE
BIGGEST LEAP FORWARD WE CAN EVER
MAKE TO ACTUALLY MOVE FORWARD
WITH CLIMATE AND CLEAN ENERGY.
WE'RE ACTUALLY BRINGING THE
LABOR COMMUNITY ALONG.
WE'RE BRINGING INVESTMENTS IN
MANUFACTURING.
WE'RE GIVING FAMILIES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR EFFICIENT
APPLIANCES SO THEY CAN SAVE
MONEY.
WE'RE LOOKING AT EFFICIENT,
CLEAN CAR TECHNOLOGIES THAT THEY
CAN NOW BE ABLE TO AFFORD.
THIS IS JUST A REMARKABLE
PLETHORA OF GOOD NEWS FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES.
>> ALL RIGHT.
NOW LET'S GET THE TAKE FROM THE
OTHER SIDE.
JOINING ME NOW, FORMER TRUMP
WHITE HOUSE COMMUNICATIONS
DIRECTOR ALYSSA FARAH GRIFFIN,
AND FORMER TRUMP CAMPAIGN
DIRECTOR DAVID URBAN.
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS BEEN RACKING
UP WINS, THE AMERICAN RECOVERY
ACT OR COVID STIMULUS PACKAGE,
NEARLY $2 TRILLION.
INFRASTRUCTURE AND JOBS ACT,
$550 BILLION.
CHIPS AND SCIENCE ACT,
$280 BILLION, AND NOW WHAT
DEMOCRATS ARE CALLING THE
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT, WHICH
IS EXPECTED TO RAISE
$700 BILLION IN GOVERNMENT
REVENUE.
NOW, DAVID, FIRST TO YOU.
YOU MAY NOT LIKE WHAT IS IN SOME
OF THESE BILLS, BUT WOULD YOU
CONCEDE THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
ONE OF THE MOST LEGISLATIVELY
SUCCESSFUL PRESIDENTS IN MODERN
HISTORY?
>> WELL, PAM, I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
THAT, AND JUST TO TAKE A STEP
BACK, YOU'RE READING OFF THESE
GIANT NUMBERS, TRILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
THAT MONEY IS NOT FREE.
THAT MONEY IS COMING FROM YOU
AND ME AND OTHER TAXPAYERS.
>> BUT IN THIS LATEST BILL, FOR
EXAMPLE, THEY HAVE WAYS OF ALSO
RAISING MONEY WITH TAXES SUCH AS
THE 15% MINIMUM TAX ON
CORPORATIONS AND SO FORTH.
BUT GO AHEAD.
BUT HOLD ON.
BUT LET'S JUST TALK ABOUT -- I
KNOW YOU WANT TO -- AS I SAID AT
THE OUTSET, DAVID, THERE ARE
GOING TO BE THINGS YOU DO NOT
LIKE IN THIS BILL.
THAT'S ONE OF THEM.
YOU THINK IT'S TOO EXPENSIVE.
BUT CAN YOU -- CAN YOU
CONCEDE --
>> SURE.
>> -- THAT, LOOK, PRESIDENT
BIDEN HAS BEEN ON A ROLL LATELY
WITH THESE WINS, WITH THESE
LEGISLATIVE WINS?
>> LISTEN, PAMELA.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S JOE BIDEN'S
ON A ROLL, BUT CHUCK SCHUMER AND
NANCY PELOSI ARE ON A ROLL.
I DIDN'T SEE JOE BIDEN UP ON THE
HILL TWISTING ARMS AND MAKING
THIS HAPPEN.
SO I WOULD WITHHOLD JUST SOME
APPLAUSE THERE.
BUT I WOULD SAY THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND DEMOCRATS
WRIT LARGE HAVE HAD A SUCCESSFUL
WEEK IN PASSING WHAT IS AN
INCREDIBLY PROGRESSIVE
LEGISLATION.
SO, YES, IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT
SUBSIDIZING TESLAS FOR THE
PROGRESSIVE WING OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THEN THEY HAD
A BIG WEEK THIS WEEK.
>> OKAY.
WELL, WE GOT TO MOVE ON BECAUSE
WE HAVE A LOT TO GET TO.
BUT IN ADDITION TO THIS, OF
COURSE, YOU HAVE LOWERING GAS
PRICES.
YOU HAVE THE JOBS REPORT THAT
CAME OUT ON FRIDAY THAT WAS
BETTER THAN EXPECTED.
ALYSSA, OF COURSE INFLATION IS
STILL A THING, BUT WHAT DO YOU
THINK?
>> SO, I MEAN, UNDOUBTEDLY THIS
WAS ONE OF THE BEST WEEKS THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS HAD IN
OFFICE, AND I WOULD ACTUALLY
NOTE THE ONE THING ALL THREE OF
US CAN AGREE ON IS TAKING OUT
ONE OF THE WORLD'S FOREMOST
TERROR.
THAT'S ALWAYS A WIN FOR AMERICA.
THAT SAID, AND I I'VE SAID THIS
BEFORE, I'M NOT CONVINCED -- YOU
KNOW, YOU COULD NAME THIS BILL
ANYTHING, BUT THAT WAS ACTUALLY
GOING TO REDUCE INFLATION.
TIME WILL TELL.
I HOPE IT DOES BY THE WAY.
I CARE MORE ABOUT AMERICANS
BEING ABLE TO AFFORD THEIR
GROCERIES AND GAS THAN I DO
DENYING A WIN TO PRESIDENT
BIDEN.
BUT IT'S LATE IN THE GAME, AND
JUST KIND OF TO GET INTO THE
POLITICS OF IT, YOU KNOW,
MIDTERMS ARE HERE, AND EVEN IF
THESE VICTORIES END UP WORKING
TO SLOWLY BRING DOWN THE
INCREDIBLY HISTORICALLY HIGH
INFLATION RATE, I DON'T THINK
IT'S ENOUGH TO REALLY SWING THE
ECONOMIC WINDS ENOUGH TO HELP
DEMOCRATS, YOU KNOW, TAKE --
CERTAINLY KEEP THE HOUSE, BUT I
ALSO THINK THE REPUBLICANS STILL
HAVE THE ADVANTAGE IN THE
SENATE.
>> AND ECONOMISTS ARE MIXED ON
WHETHER THIS BILL WILL ACTUALLY
REDUCE INFLATION, BUT I WANT TO
ASK ABOUT SOMETHING ELSE.
YOU HAVE CPAC GOING ON THIS PAST
WEEK.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP BECAUSE
DURING HIS SPEECH AT CPAC LAST
NIGHT, HE WENT AFTER SOMEONE YOU
KNOW WELL, CASSIDY HUTCHINSON,
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT HER TESTIMONY
THAT TRUMP HAD A CONFRONTATION
WITH THE SECRET SERVICE AND ALSO
THREW FOOD AT THE WALLS OF THE
WHITE HOUSE.
LISTEN.
>> I KNOW THESE PEOPLE.
THESE ARE VERY STRONG PEOPLE.
IT'S JUST NOT MY DEAL.
AND I STARTED TO CHOKE.
SO WHEN THE STORY CAME OUT, SOME
PEOPLE -- I SAID, I NEVER KNEW
YOU WERE THAT STRONG PHYSICALLY.
AND THEN THEY SAID I STARTED
THROWING FOOD ALL OVER THE WHITE
HOUSE.
NO.
I HAVE TOO MUCH RESPECT FOR THE
WHITE HOUSE.
BUT THAT SOMEBODY COULD SORT OF
BELIEVE.
YOU KNOW THAT.
BUT TO THINK THAT I'M GOING TO
BE JUMPING INTO THE SEAT,
GRABBING THE WHEEL, BEING
REBUFFED, GRABBING THIS BIG
POWERFUL GUY.
HIS NECK IS LIKE THIS, AND I'M
GOING TO TAKE HIM.
>> AND THIS IS THE SAME EVENT
THAT FEATURED AN EXHIBIT WITH AN
ACTUAL CONVICTED JANUARY 6th
RIOTER FAKE-CRYING IN A FAKE
PRISON CELL.
ALYSSA, WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO
ALL OF THAT?
>> LISTEN, UNFORTUNATELY CPAC,
WHICH ATTENDED FOR MANY YEARS,
HAS KIND OF DEVOLVED INTO JUST
LIKE PERFORMANCE ART.
IT'S THE ENTERTAINMENT WING OF
THE GOP.
THAT BIT THAT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT DID, SURE, HE CAN MAKE
LIGHT OF THE ONE PIECE OF
CASSIDY HUTCHINSON'S TESTIFY
THAT WAS HEARSAY.
IT WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS SHARED
WITH HER BY TONY RENATO.
BUT OF COURSE HE DOESN'T TOUCH
THE COUNTLESS CLAIMS THAT SHE
MADE ABOUT HIM WANTING PEOPLE TO
COME ARMED ONTO THE ELLIPSE THAT
DAY, SAYING THEY'RE NOT HERE TO
HURT ME, KNOWING THEY WERE THERE
TO HURT OTHERS.
HE DOESN'T ADDRESS THE SUBSTANCE
OF THE INVESTIGATION BEHIND
JANUARY 6th, AND HONESTLY IS
MAKING LIGHT OF ONE OF THE
DARKEST DAYS IN NOT JUST HIS
PRESIDENCY BUT AMERICAN HISTORY,
AND I THINK IT'S FAIRLY
SHAMEFUL.
>> DAVID, TO YOU, FLORIDA
SENATOR RICK SCOTT, WHO CHAIRS
THE NATIONAL REPUBLICAN
SENATORIAL COMMITTEE MADE A
COMMENT THAT VOTERS SHOULD ELECT
CANDIDATES THEY'D BE WILLING TO
HIRE.
BUT WHEN HE WAS ASKED THIS
MORNING ABOUT APPLYING THAT SAME
STANDARD TO CANDIDATES LIKE
HERSCHEL WALKER IN GEORGIA, HERE
WAS HIS ANSWER.
>> IN GEORGIA, HERSCHEL WALKER
HAS LIED ABOUT THE NUMBER OF
CHILDREN HE HAS, ABOUT HIS
BUSINESS DEALINGS.
HIS EX-WIFE SAID HE HELD A GUN
TO HER HEAD AND SAID, I'M GOING
TO BLOW YOUR F-ING BRAINS OUT.
IN ARZ, THE CANDIDATE, BLAKE
MASTERS, CALLED UNABOMBER AN
UNDERRATED THINKER.
WOULD YOU HIRE THESE PEOPLE TO
WORK FOR YOU?
>> WELL, YOU'D GO THROUGH EACH
PERSON, BUT I'M NOT THE ONE
DOING IT.
THE VOTERS OF THOSE STATES ARE
GOING TO MAKE A CHOICE.
>> YOU'RE TRYING TO HELP SENATE
REPUBLICANS AND LEAD THEM TO
VICTORY.
THESE ARE YOUR CANDIDATES.
>> IS THAT A SUFFICIENT ANSWER,
DAVID?
>> YEAH, THAT'S A -- WELL,
PAMELA, LOOK, THAT'S KIND OF
UNFAIR BY MARGARET TO SAY THAT
BECAUSE RICK SCOTT DIDN'T
HAND-PICK THESE PEOPLE.
THESE PEOPLE WERE ELECTED BY THE
REPUBLICANS THIS THEIR STATE.
THEY HAVE A PRIMARY RACE.
THEIR NAMES ARE ON THE BALLOT.
THIS INFORMATION'S OUT THERE,
AND PEOPLE MAKE A CHOICE.
PEOPLE MADE A CHOICE WHEN THEY
KNEW DONALD TRUMP -- THEY HAD
HEARD THE "ACCESS HOLLYWOOD"
TAPES.
THEY WENT TO THE POLLS.
THEY WERE FULLY AWARE OF THOSE
COMMENTS THAT HE MADE, AND THEY
MADE A CHOICE.
THEY MAKE A CHOICE IN EVERY
ELECTION.
THEY MAKE A CHOICE, YOU KNOW,
WHEN YOU GO TO THE POLLS,
THEY'RE FULLY INFORMED AS TO
WHAT THEY'RE VOTING ON, AND THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE GET WHAT THEY
DESERVE.
BY THE WAY, BACK TO THE
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT EARLIER, THE PENN
WHARTON BUDGET MODEL SAID IT'S
GOING TO HAVE ZERO IMPACT ON
REDUCING INFLATION.
SO JUST TO PUT A LITTLE FLAG
POINT ON THAT.
>> YOU JUST CAN'T LET IT GO, CAN
YOU, DAVID?
AS I SAID EARLIER, ECONOMISTS
HAVE BEEN MIXED ABOUT WHETHER IT
WILL ACTUALLY REDUCE INFLATION,
AND